what's up recheck nation aaron we back
at it buddy
what's cracking here again umbrella
academy
season two episode five assassin's creed
valhalla
so guys in case you if you haven't heard
me say this already
only allows for 10 minutes worth of the
show to be shown
if we're lucky and lately we've been
lucky so these are only reaction
highlights full length reaction watch
alongs are over at our patreon page
patreon plug incoming over our patreon
we cover a lot of tv
shows that have the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs all at the
same tier
those shows are supernatural doctor who
joshua's our adventures the promise
neverland
attack outside death note my hero
academia cookie house one punch man
full metal alchemist brotherhood violet
evergarden demon slayer and we do a lot
of shows that's
the only watch alongs for we also got a
weekly q a podcast we'd love it if you
guys would go ahead
and share your support by becoming a
patronage today
that's how you naturally sell someone on
your patreon page
[Music]
what the hell pogo
[Music]
[Laughter]
so she's a scientist i love how when she
first is introduced she doesn't come
across
not like this at all no he never knows
your scientists judgmental mind of
men here oh
greens you think he's checking her out
but it's really the
it's really the monkey i'm not in it for
you
[Laughter]
pogo
the adventures you went on pogo the
adventure
is that a real animal i hope it's very
real
yeah it looks like it's trippy
my little pogo oh what you know
pogo uh oh
he's he'll be fine this is a flashbang
he's fine
oh no oh
poor pogo are they gonna put a human
brain in there oh
no low to face pogo pogo dent damn
i love how she gets cpr to the beat
you're not doing it right now you gotta
catch up oh she's giving him the luther
serum
make him a super monkey
oh yeah that no he only does it to once
he really cares about that he said [ __ ]
ben though
wow look how real that looks wow
eternally tripping balls
oh super healing
oh my little pogo baby
my little baby oh look at
they're gonna be your family pogo drew
oh who are you're a man you
act like one that's a fair excuse but
still oh
that's your man oh if this was 2020
well that was are bad liars do you go
smart too
yeah bye oh he's not just walking away
[Laughter]
why does he tell them about ben right
don't they already know
enablers i was just gonna say don't you
love when your siblings enable you to
your problems
wow
[Laughter]
nice everything they do i'm just like
yeah share that coffee
it's like people forget about morning
breath
apocalypse is around the corner
oh don't die [ __ ] i was thinking the
same thing
don't die that's what how's she gonna
get her powers back how she gotta join
the team
she has something to fight for now
i bet the swedes are gonna kill her what
the swedes are going to kill her
what do you mean the swedes are going to
kill you read that no i didn't read that
i that's what i think that's why they
said i read that no
why would i say it
that's
away at the awful that's not exactly
true
you've interacted with him
oh snap okay
so luther just like breaks my heart this
season yeah
he's just like a big teddy bear it's a
big old lug
so it's like his solo indie movie
what was your goal we're trying to get
to he said he just goes to a small town
and just
kind of inhabits there for a little bit
to find himself that's kind of smart
but he would make sense for him to do
that
i was totally having that question like
why did nobody try to find their dad
even see if he was around
you were quite the entertainer back then
reginald very charming
someone get this man on rose battles
it's time to get the umbrella back
together oh yeah
they're so resistant
i think they're getting along this
season it's crazy
like a re-establishment of their dynamic
now yeah they're actually like
like act like civil rights
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah gross
hitting her button uh-oh don't kill carl
oh she's gonna kill oh no vania no
watch yourself on you get my heart ass
out oh
oh i'm so worried vanilla's going to
send a toy oh i thought she's going to
break him
they have a connection oh because he put
the essence in him did
she give him powers
oh dude don't go cold on vanya now
no she loves you [ __ ] says she's
confused
you're right
oh my god fun is gay
[Music]
what i could tell by the window breaking
[Laughter]
diego's knife oh
huh he was a sneaky
you don't know he's going to make
conversation elliot
silence is always sometimes the best
answer oh they got it ah
they get behind you there oh well that
makes sense why she's there now would
you say you are on a scale from winter
on this planet oh
yes
sorry if that means anything
i love their relationship this season i
love all these characters this season
yes oh hey i thought she liked me
she wants to sleep with five you should
like five more than me
oh the umbrella academy is united
they're bad [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you all get sexier
oh so that didn't trigger her
who are you i don't know you
i wonder if they're going to keep her
memory erased and like give her a chance
to be a new banyan
or she'll remember at the last minute
and start everybody well she's also made
these new memories with them so she can
see that they've
kind of improved
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
they united in the first episode of
season one but it feels more special now
yeah it feels it feels because we know
who know who they are
exactly and they feel like different
characters
oh this is all cute oh that's [ __ ] up
did he did she just kill the cat i think
she did
what are your new orders
what is he acting like this is the first
time he's ever seen something like that
is this like a completely different one
or something they're all acting like
it's something strange
what about diego they got to kill him
it's a good thing they know what he
looks like now
because of fighting in the hallway right
i'm sure there's also a little grudge
there he did throw him out of windows
[Laughter]
that's great this is awesome
in three days to kill the president so i
think we all know what we have to do
kill dad
knew it
[Laughter]
suspicious ass klaus who do you think is
actually the leader of this
this superhero team
i don't know if the things we've
experienced here are all connected
dude i don't know if there's a reason
for everything five i love you man dad
we need to talk to him before everyone
and everything we know is dead
that's not captivating
oh that's like the opposite of last
season wow where did dick
oh no did he time travel
what
what are you doing
[Laughter]
poor ben include ben klaus why are you
leaving him out of the conversation
everything's out in the open
let him be there
[Music]
i think diego's the best hero at all oh
har graves you're really old man as hard
as inviting them to the
house that guy's super old that's a
really old man
he should be working all right
the plan's working kind of let's see
what happens
you know exactly who i am i mean
there's all the time travel stuff and
you're from a different life this was a
lot of things
that daughter yeah
[Laughter]
oh thank you for addressing this
technically technically if you use your
left words use the word technically
you're already in trouble we can at
least try to save my marriage
no it's like asking a nun how to hump
someone's leg
in secret love with some farm frown
which is an improvement on her previous
love interest the serial killer
[Laughter]
the healthiest long-term relationship in
this family
was when fine was banging that message
somebody gift that cross-eyed look
no much else
don't do that oh it's so sweet though so
genuine
i don't think it's gonna go well i just
hate group breakups that's why i stopped
dating twins
i love this i like that she's actually
included
oh this is awesome dude this is so great
that it's like
they're a family yeah that's the that's
probably the best thing this season is
going for
their chemistry and the way they write
their interactions now is just so much
better but their experiences from
season one karen over here still feel
natural exactly with the progression of
them being like a family and especially
giving them a time jump gives them time
to kind of change the different
characters but still remain that similar
aspect to them like they've been at par
for so long and then when they come back
like this you know
yeah they never thought they'd see each
other again and not by choice oh that
was a great show that was great that's
cool those are great match cuts
this is so much fun
all right let's sit down
this diego [ __ ] oh is she going to kill
them it's a trap
oh did she she set the thing oh
oh that's why i was on the roof okay
oh make her think it's diego they
planted the
message they got to hunt diego that's
why they were acting all weird about it
because
i think it came it was a different type
of tube and it came from someplace else
right did you already know that and i
like just put it together now
[Laughter]
she just dropped it she's like oh jeez
she's not playing innocent anymore okay
or might be part of the plan from uh her
and handler
damn look at five's martial arts moves
on double
that's not clearly not
what the hell whoa what the hell
what's your deal
what how is she moving this fast what
does she have powers
she wants what are you woman are you a
robot
you're not real ah
[Music]
he talks more like reginald than anyone
else i can definitely see that she's
going to confess her love for [ __ ]
i hope so i feel things pretty soon no
she's in a pull away
don't do this
oh no don't do this don't do this
don't do this oh [ __ ]
oh no you caught me [ __ ]
no
she's gonna kill him going to kill
that man gets to be happy all the time
that was just morning talk why tell each
other to get through the damn day
no don't break her heart
hmm
what are you going to say characters
always do that like what else is there
to say
ellen page has a very specific walk yeah
oh no what
oh they're setting him off
this is a swedish adele cover i just
picked up on the fact that it
isn't what the song was
i just picked up on that oh my god
everything she's not going to believe
you i slept with all those white boys
the cop too everyone
oh those swedes are feeling a passion
now uh-oh
revenge time it just got
personal oh what is over
[Laughter]
wow i thought we were just gearing up
for like another crazy scene
that's how netflix scoops you in i was
so into that that i
like when it ended i wasn't because a
lot of times these episodes are ending
you could feel it wrapping up
right and i was like i was like oh
that's an excellent [ __ ] it's just gonna
be crazy in the next scene
that's how netflix scoops you in it was
like oh we're not gonna end it like a
show
like it's the scene because you're gonna
keep watching well the academy is
officially united
siblings united so great and ben's there
he doesn't even
they don't even realize he's still there
why is claus still keeping ben
out of the picture though that doesn't
quite make sense to me yet i'm like why
what's the point they would want to know
that their brother's there yeah and can
he manifest him at any time because he's
got control over his powers now
and there's a maybe that's something he
just doesn't want to do it's like klaus
has any secrets
right now he's very open about
everything he's like not hiding the fact
that he's drinking he calls it a cult
like straight up you know so why are you
are you keeping it hidden the thing with
this that i think they've really
reinvented for this season is the family
bonds like
100 we keep saying they feel like actual
siblings
everything feels very appropriate on
terms of the kind of dialogue exchanges
they're having at each particular time
that we're checking in with them and
even with
you know this whole thing with the
memory wipe i wasn't sure how i would
feel about it it's allowed to take away
all that like resentment and resentment
from the last season
yeah all the resentment she felt towards
her family and the amount of feeling
left out and now just feeling like she
you know i want to feel part of the
family and
then just kind of rolling with her and
accepting her and even diego diego was
the one who acknowledges
you know like oh last time you know she
was sucking the life force out of me you
think
tentacles yeah you think he's just gonna
be mad and she says i'm sorry and
he lets it go and with who diego is now
i buy that whereas in first season of
who he was then
he was gonna hold the crunch all season
here i know the question for his father
forever but
yeah like they've changed all the
dynamics and interactions with everyone
more than just personality shifts
literally the way they all
interact i mean right down to luther and
diego too
yeah they actually feel like brothers
that can have a civil conversation
season one felt like a dysfunctional
family this season feels like a family
reuniting who are like remembering what
it's like to be siblings
because they're all kind of getting
pushed down on their luck times are
feeling
like the worst for them and i think with
season one it was this sense
we're at our worst when we're together
yeah and then
now it's at this point of we're at our
worst as individuals and we're
we feel better when we're together yeah
having to deal with the worst situation
possible
yeah i love about this season is they're
actually giving the chance
to have characters bond in like a like a
healthy fun way that they really didn't
do in the first season like actually
getting to see klaus and allison bond
and then klaus allison and bonnie all
bonding together this scene was so much
fun that was a blast that made me so
happy well even with luther
like i'm really the scene with luther
diego when they're talking to each other
really stands out to me because they
still have that competitive kind of
judgmental thing towards each other
but they also have this level of
understanding and compassion
backed up with their dialogue i'm loving
everything they're doing with the fam
like especially with all them together
because the show has already been great
in this season and they've been most of
them in the park and then so when
they're all together
and now it's really exciting it is nice
yeah
it's like they're they're all all having
their own journeys
in this the show collectively and then
they come together and it's like the
avengers reuniting it just feels nice
and it feels good to have them all in
one place again the reunion
feels grounded in this real strong
emotional subtext it feels earned
because yeah they have to be together
because they have to stop the apocalypse
so i get it like they
they have to yeah like this is literally
their job like that's like
yeah they're the ones at this place they
have to be the one to fix it yet
what the show's done such a good job at
doing is now that they're united it
feels like they
want to be united because of how they
feel towards one another
right it's not through circumstances
through desire it's not like ah crap
we're a bunch of misfits you don't want
to do this it's
no we they they have you kind of forget
about the whole apocalypse thing and
that's why they're together
you're just happy they're together yeah
and i think the thing that this show
does
so great so far it man get you to care
about these characters and make their
relationships feel organic while also
getting you really intrigued in the plot
and the goofiness and
the intrigue of the the 60s environment
that the show's kind of
inhabited this is really great stuff
like i said in the last time we watched
this
was yeah the end of the world's coming
but i love how most of them
the main intrigue is not in terms of the
mystery plot it's not really
preventing the apocalypse it's what's
going on with reginald hargraves
what's going on with this jfk
assassination like that's all the stuff
i'm like
itching to uncover oh yeah i'm pogo the
pogo journal the pogo's adventures man
man pogo's ape escape even though it was
made
dude getting like hints of this
backstory of oh grace
and reginald really seemed like they
were a thing and they they were
intimate the bonding through pogo
can't see past like why he got rid of
her accent
it was just like i loved everything
about her but her voice
it's too close to home you can look like
her but you can't yeah and how pogo
really felt
like a ch a child that he loved right
which is weird because you know you have
this scene with luther which i'm so glad
we got that scene because
it it it's in line with who luther is as
a character
of where we left off with him that's
something he would do and i'm glad one
of the characters decided to do it
right it makes sense and you get this
taste of it would be him too exactly
you you get this taste of uh wretched
toy where he's like have having dinner
hosting parties and he likes to bond and
have
fun there's this woman that he was in
love with but also worked with talks
about how he hates kids but pogo he
really loved like his own son
that actually further drives home that
whole reasoning for why
pogo was ridiculously loyal too reginald
that makes sense and the question i had
during the scene where he was basically
roasting luther was okay during that
confrontation
luther's been here for what like two
he's been here for like what a year
right they said that a year no no luther
was
luther got on the bus and no i'm saying
he he got dropped in the 60s and he's
only been there for oh yeah yeah yeah so
i'm wondering if the pogo stuff
with him kind of raising him and giving
him the serum if that happens before
or after luther comes to see him at that
point he's like i hate children but then
pogo's basically his child
so did po did the experience with pogo
soften him to having children i'm not
sure i
i think he really just viewed his
children like experiments
yeah which as he was talking luther i'm
like that makes sense why are you
raising my head yeah
i don't like kids dog yeah toning in man
i really appreciate
uncovering the history with grace
because when you see her in the last
episode i'm like oh she was just some
like
hot girl that reginald she's talking
about men flirting with her and stuff
that
i thought she was just one of those you
know dream darlings
and uh is that a phrase
and then seeing her here like oh he's
actually like a super smart scientist
cool
yeah with everything with pogo too it's
just so grand to see like
pogo was like the start of so much
little pogo is so adorable give me a
little pogo shirt
yeah someone should make a little pogo i
think they really pay attention to the
questions audiences might
ask specifically what greg will ask
like with lila and the handler when we
saw the lyle's backstory
my mind kept going wait you saw that
this woman killed your parents and yet
you're
you're so attached to her and call her
mom and you haven't tried to get away
like you don't hate her
from some of the dialogue that you're
getting here somehow the ham
i mean maybe lyle's biological parents
were messed up but somehow the handler
has really
had it ingrained into lila her killing
lila's parents
was a good thing hey i have a small
hunch that maybe the hand is a little
bit manipulative
i don't know man nah that's probably
[ __ ] yeah
it's probably [ __ ] i don't know what
gave you that clue
but having the scenes address it in a
way that feels for the most part natural
[ __ ] and vonyam what i think is great
about makes this more compelling
is the fact that oh yeah it makes more
sense that sissy's the one who's dealing
with complexity of the situation and
it's not vania who's like no
you shouldn't trust me or whatever yeah
it would be
this woman and sissy's position and
granted like finding deals with a lot of
crazier pressures but at the same time
vanya wouldn't
understand what this position is like
for [ __ ] and how difficult this
is so yeah you're kind of up and leaving
your family out of nowhere it's like a
scary thing for anybody to do especially
for a closeted lesbian woman in the 60s
like yeah it's gonna
she wouldn't want to be up in a band in
her life especially with vania talking
about you only have six days
right what are you talking about yeah it
was a heartbreaking scene i feel bad for
vanya i'm glad none of it's getting
repetitive
of season one because every time
something bad goes wrong i'm like i'm
gonna stab a boogie if i can kill
everyone
he's going to blow up the town
definitely has a
unique feel definitely no retreaded
waters even with the swedes
totally different kind of approach that
they're taking with that antagonist i
don't know if people responded
negatively
to hazel and joshua i don't know if
people did but i love them
great i thought they were awesome that
was what was refreshing about hazel and
chacha they seemed like people who
couldn't pull off any job like this
right and then as it kept going you're
like oh damn these guys are good yeah
they just seem like they're not at first
yeah it's like um
kind of like that uh that drunken monkey
syndrome you know yeah like
you think they're bad but actually like
really lethal but the thing yeah the
thing with the swedes is like they're
kind of going over that trope of like
these deadly silent
assassins yeah there's nothing really
about them that feels entirely
unique i mean and i i appreciate this
effort of
especially with the brother dying and
them being very traditional i don't need
to love these guys
i i'm all together not fascinated by
them they just seem like kind of cliche
but they don't take a
majority of any of the episodes so i i
overall i'm already finding this to be
an improvement in a lot of ways
over season one even though i love
season one but you know it's not without
some things that i'm like ah
the swedes are the i don't like dislike
them i just feel like
they're just the weakest link the least
appealing
new addition to the show yeah yeah they
don't replace
hazel and shots off from the last year
but lila i really like now
um the relationship with [ __ ] uh and
vanya i think is great
yeah this is awesome let's let's tune in
in a couple days for the next one people
subscribe click notification bells check
out
the full-length on patreon do it all bye
oh wait page for the day shout out
katie anne katie ann katie ann has a
wonderful blog site through
thelookingclass.water.blog
it's clever i like it through the
looking class and then a while ago she
sent this package
to john and i she said don't open until
the letter is here
because she sent it separately i'm
waiting for that letter to come
i've just been staring at this package
for many days
wondering what's in it thinking there's
going to be some
small possibly pervy creature
popping out of it wanting to ruin my
life and take over the town
gremlins i'm referencing gremlins right
now
i just wanted to tell you thank you so
much for being you always contributing
to our live streams too love you on the
discord you're a talented girl
congratulations on getting double
certified
and i can't wait to see the special
objects that you have put
in here to improve minor libya's sex
life
the kremlin
[Music]
you